I want you to meet this gentleman
Richard Richard is from Hollywood where
he's a producer in the movie and music
business say hi to Richard hey Richard
what's up hey how you doing Howard how
you doing Kathy yeah hi love your story
and I I love you know I just I love your
attitude and that's what I fell in love
with Richard wants everyone to know he
has a great sense of humor he produced a
music CD called pull my finger it was
comprised entirely of fart sounds in
fact let me play a clip this is a hit
called silent but deadly night what was
this this was a farting I think two
silent right yeah yeah Christmas songs
wait he was farting no who farted on
this record Richard well we have we had
over uh 10 people create farts for this
real actual farts um we made a
documentary of it at pullmyfinger.com
you can see a free documentary all right
let me play it
[Music]
hmm
fabulous
I'll go out with you
[Laughter]
when you were making this anyone [__]
their pants
yeah yes yeah that is covered in the
dock but yes wow and you use some of
your own farts right you saw my own
farts react and we actually secretly put
uh microphones inside of a toilet bowl
when people were taking crabs we would
actually perhaps
Kathy just actually walked with Kathy
you're a little turned off to this uh
it's not my thing like bathroom type
stuff and farting you're a fan of this
show I love this show I love it
listening to the show it was 20 years
ago the guy's matured and by the way
I'll let you brag a little bit Richard
how big is your penis oh
oh how many inches of seven and seven
inches yeah a nice size Kathy writing it
down I think
that's important Kathy I'm curious what
did you just write down I see you John I
literally wrote seven inches
as if I forget it
foreign